how are you gonna hold this team
together over the long haul you got
Tyreke he'll you got Chris Jones you got
Patrick my home's gonna be eligible for
a contract yeah sure I mean there's
gonna be a lot of yeah yeah I mean
listen it's um you know it's a good
thing to have great players but also
there's there's you know the reality of
having a cap and staying under that it's
gonna be challenging and there were
certain things that we have to do but
it's a good problem to have and I think
teams would want to have those type of
problems now it's kind of funny I'd
forgot in that moment I'm asking the guy
a real question and Sims is heckling him
while I'm asking you got trouble the pot
a little bit and I like it he's a great
guy too yes yes you're right they got it
they got like issues that I think if you
and I were both running the Kansas City
Chiefs we'd go about this is awesome I
have these type of issues but either way
they're issues that they have but they
have some talented freaky awesome type
players that they're gonna have to pay
big money to and they're gonna have some
guys they're gonna have to be willing to
say goodbye to that's the problem
they're kind of going through the
Seattle Seahawks thing without ever
winning the Super Bowl where you've got
guys like Justin Houston Eric Barry
eventually Travis Kelce they're gonna
have to cycle off the roster and you're
gonna have to hope you can keep drafting
great young players who are cheap see
that's where the rookie wage scale helps
a team and hurts a veteran you're less
likely to keep an expensive veteran
around because you think hey we'll roll
the dice on a few draft picks right pay
these guys a lot less we'll save a ton
of money and maybe we get lucky and find
a guy who can play yeah I mean that's
exactly right it's always about the the
younger guy you get the younger guy plus
you get the younger guy who was a lot
cheaper than the veteran the veteran guy
who of course has a little wear and tear
on his tires regardless but the Kansas
City Chiefs I mean in this conversation
all together hey I understand Justin
Houston they're gonna let him go it's
that time in his career he's a good
football player still but he's not the
player that we saw a few years back that
was flirting with the you know all-time
single-season sack record with 22 sacks
and all those things he's had little
knee issues that he's had to worry with
so I get that and then moving on there
now there was a talk of like them
getting may be trading D Ford that's
I don't buy into quite yet I mean D Ford
is kind of at that prime point of his
career like at the start of the show we
talked about Frank Clark right Mike
where he did some special things this
year and him and Chris Jones were by far
and away the two most talented guys and
biggest difference makers on that Chiefs
defense this year to where I would think
they would keep him at least for this
year through the franchise tag and at
least continue to talk about whether
they want to sign him to a long-term
deal yeah and I think that part of this
relates to the fight that could be
looming that should be looming between D
Ford and the Chiefs over whether he's a
defensive end or an outside linebacker
we touched on this briefly yesterday
there's only one point seven million in
the balance but that's still 1.7 million
and when you're talking about a
long-term deal the more you bump up the
front end the more the dollars flow in
years two three four and five and three
when I saw the original report over the
weekend that the Chiefs are thinking
about trading him because they're not
sure whether he fits in this move to a
4-3 that's a load of crap low right an
outside linebacker in a three-four is a
defensive end in a 4-3 you put your hand
in the dirt and you put and you rush the
passer it doesn't matter what the label
is on third and long you're going after
the quarterback period I don't care what
I don't care how the seven guys up front
or allocated from a title standpoint
that's what you do and I feel like the
Chiefs know what's coming they know that
Ford is going to point out hey I'm a
defensive end now in this new defense
and I think that they want to be able to
say to an arbitrator at some point well
we're not sure where he fits and this
report helps helps kind of you know
spread the seeds as all as this gets
rolling down the road weeks or months
from now when they figure out whether or
not he should be a defensive end or an
outside linebacker for franchise tag
purposes yes exactly right and I mean
honestly hey three four four three just
what you're talking about
yeah the Chiefs were primarily a three
for base defense the last few years
under Bob Sutton but Mike they barely
played the three four they were in
nickel defense I would bet you eight
nine out of ten snaps somewhere in that
range so 80 to 90 percent of the time
they are
playing a four down front where D Ford
was a DN so I think the Kansas City
Chiefs when they dive into the numbers
and this becomes something that's in
front of an arbiter you know what how do
you say that word arbitrator thank you
exactly right that word right there when
that gets in front of them they're gonna
argue that he plays defense and a whole
lot more than outside linebacker and
that's what he needs to be paid
accordingly - I totally needs to be a
defense that not an outside linebacker
you know I shouldn't have told you that
it's arbitrator because now I'm very
curious what you would have said
arbitrarily tell it's a lot of different
things there I wasn't sure actually
correct in some contexts all right I
just thought you had something really
creative that would have been very
entertaining
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports